ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show I was watching the nude and
by the way happy holidays to all of you
that are celebrating anything this year
whether it's Christmas
um and what we're doing here on the show
that's a joke it's a Hanukkah Kwanzaa
which is what me and my family celebrate
uh the winter solstice which is a
beautiful seasonal celebration uh
whatever it is out there that you're
celebrating we hope you enjoy it and we
hope the holiday season is
um you know Bountiful plentiful whatever
uh Harry and Megan hit the Netflix
uh over the weekend and uh or yesterday
and uh I got an email it's like a
documentary you may enjoy
um and it's the it's the documentary
Harry and Megan about Prince Harry
and his wife Meghan Markle uh the
actress from Suits
and
I don't know what to think because I
have a very negative opinion of these
two just from my own
um the thing with me is I'm I'm a pretty
good judge of character and the reason
that I'm a good judge of character is
because I don't I don't deal in extremes
I deal in extremes when it's funny when
I go you know when I'm making a funny
point but but people are usually not all
good or all bad
um usually uh they have like for Hitler
for example was no I'm kidding but to
see Meghan Markle to me there are
certain things about her as a character
in the documentary you watch and they're
sympathetic right she is caught between
two worlds she's black but doesn't
really look black so I get it I totally
understand what you know growing up in
that type of environment and then being
thrust into
um this this you know royal family and
the press in Britain is crazy and
um you know they're vicious they're more
vicious than the American Press but also
as you're watching this documentary
something begins to happen there's
little tells here and it's not this is
not an attack
per se on Meghan Markle and her autistic
husband
it would because he is I mean and
there's nothing wrong with that but he's
being led
now there's little tells that start to
happen throughout the documentary where
you go
something because in the beginning of
the documentary it's actually very nice
in the beginning of the documentary it's
like she's like at Wimbledon and he's
like would you like to have drinks and
it's a whole thing and
you know he's late the first time he's a
little late and she's like well I'm not
going to do that you know she said when
she's on the interview and he's like
well you mean and she's like well you
know a man that has such a big ego and
shows up late like there's little things
you go okay that's fine you know I guess
she thought that he was telegraphing his
importance but maybe it was maybe she
was also just kind of like not thinking
there could be a traffic or something
and there's little tell and then one of
the things that gets me where she goes
she goes when I first met the queen I
didn't know I was meeting the queen and
then Harry goes uh do you know how to
cut see and she goes she goes I thought
it was a joke
[ __ ] what do you mean you thought it
was a joke she's the queen of [ __ ]
England this is when you start to
realize something is off
something is wrong something doesn't
feel right
she's the queen of England what do you
mean you didn't know you're gonna have
to curtsy in front of her
nobody gets Famous by accident rarely
and certainly nobody stays Famous by
accident
nobody starts dating the prince of
whatever it is over there I don't even
know what his title is but
Sussex or Essex or the Duke of York I
don't know whatever he nobody starts
dating him they know
anybody who grew up in her era get
Meghan markle's age up because I bet her
age and my age are similar
I'm 37. I bet Meghan Markle is 30 41.
even older
grew up watching the Royals she knew how
big of a deal they were she knew about
Charles and Diana she knew how the Press
if we're to believe the story and we
might
the Press killed the other [ __ ] they
killed Diana they killed that [ __ ] in
the tunnel they killed her they ran her
off the road this is how crazy the
British press was that your your
boyfriend's mother was killed by them
so this idea that this documentary
starts where she's like I I was like
unprepared for the level of scrutiny
that I was receiving like being
and I get it I get it
that it's it's unsettling
when you were in Toronto shooting suits
and people are in their in their cars
bothering you because they want photo
let's by the way I want you to watch the
official trailer I don't want to take
eight
because yeah I could already tell people
like you're going after a black woman
again stop it her friends are all wide
cut it out
it's like her saying that she's had a
lot of problems because of her race it's
like me saying I'm discriminated against
every day because I'm gay Meg it's just
not true yes people have called me a
[ __ ] but it's not every day at coffee
so now when she did start boinking this
freak what happened with this inbred guy
who's a sweet guy but he's inbred and
he's all over the place nobody believes
he fought in what war over there let's
cut it out he didn't do anything in
Afghanistan you know and he goes to
Africa and he they let him you know do
juggle with the monkeys and stuff and I
mean the actual monkeys like I mean he's
doing conservation that's what he does
like I'm not trying to it's not slurs
this is literally he likes animal he
goes everything that's a warthog and
they go yes go to you know go feed it
water
um and and he but he's not I mean come
up conservation is what you do when you
know it's he's not exactly like the
pride of the state right they send him
to I mean Britain is a little racist
it's like the the most important person
over over there you don't send them to
Africa to you know study like rhinoceros
you know whatever irrigation systems so
he's a little off and and and and Megan
Markle his uh love
um you know meets this guy and and I
don't know what people say I get the
racial thing and I get that the Press
was vicious to her and I get people
online suck so they're they during this
documentary they show all these comments
about people saying he's a race Trader
and horrible thing I get listen I get it
people are racist people are bad people
Anonymous people online are crazy
my whole thing is trying to get to the
bottom of what this really is because
they got a hundred million dollars from
Netflix to talk about what happened I'm
not done with the documentary I still
don't know what happened but for right
now it seems like this was a little bit
of a play
from her
and it was smart and it was pretty sharp
and kudos to her hats off to her because
she's got a hundred mil and they're up
in Montecito and she's got this guy who
she's with who has no idea what's going
on I fully believe he's unaware of what
I think she tells him I think she goes
to him in the night and goes your mother
called me the n-word you saw my Mother's
Day my mother's dead my mother is dead
and she goes well your other mother that
old [ __ ] oh the queen Mommy called you
what again she called me the n-word and
she used the r at the end
I and then his law oh no what should we
do and she goes we're going to Montecito
where's that it's an it's in California
and I'm gonna be a star
because remember she's an actor she
always wanted to be famous she always
wanted to be a famous star and
the royal family are inbred reptilian uh
uh the overlords of the anglo-american
uh fading Empire over there so you have
inbred reptilian they feed off negative
energy they convert it to power and they
uh and that's how they live and that's
how they've lived forever and they live
forever and they are strange looking
pale kind of gaunt and they have the
eyes that are and the you know and but
they don't really have opinions about
anything other than that they need to
feed off the negative energy that comes
with the death and the pillage and the
the droughts and the floods and all the
things that keep them coming now
otherwise they're just like a normal
family a vampire energy uh you know
freaks that's just what they are but
they don't wade into controversial
topics often they just don't that's
something they are like the real power
structure in the sense of like they
don't have any political power because
politics is fake they just want like it
okay here comes the infant cook and know
they cook it you know they just watch
cooking shows and they eat all the
children that disappear from the British
orphanages and and but they're not but
they don't they're not like they're the
trans bathroom issue it's not what they
do they are just old school and there's
something nice about that there's
something nice about tradition there's
something nice about tradition that old
[ __ ] as long as you gave her a baby
every morning plumped up cooked nice
like not not American bacon where it's
nice and crispy but nice and cooked and
charred and you gave her the leg of an
infant with some baked beans and a [ __ ]
whatever she was good she didn't need to
get political and there's something nice
about this tradition it's tradition
they're an inbred uh Royal uh cannibal
vampire family now Meghan Markle is a
Hollywood actress is very similar that's
a very similar thing they're actually
one in the same they're not that
different she pretends to be other
people all the time she doesn't really
know who she is when you get the vibe
when when you hear her that she's
carefully curating this
image of herself which is what everyone
I've met who's a real actor not the
brilliant actors they're just insane and
not the people like me who like do these
little you know bit Parts where I'm like
I don't know what I even do like is the
tomato and you know but what I mean is
like you know actors the vast majority
of them are constantly curating the
parts of themselves they want to be
known at any given time right and
there's parts of the documentary where
Meghan markle's like you know I was
always the I was always the smart one
people think that I was like the hot one
but I was always the girl who was trying
to be smart because you aren't hot yet
you weren't hot yet once you got hot you
stopped with that [ __ ] you cut that out
and then you went to become an actress
and again A lot of people are going to
hear this is an attack on Markle I
actually respect Markle I respect her
because she ran a good high level scam
and she separated uh this guy from his
family uh to the tune of a hundred big
ones 100 sticks 100 Mil nothing wrong
with that in the gray and scheme of
things right
you know it is what it is but let's
watch the trailer here I don't want to
taint any of your perspective Chrysler's
wife by the way I think agrees with me
on this because they FaceTime me once
and I went on this rant and Leanne was
going yes yes yes and Christina P does
women and wives get it
they get it and if you're not imposing
your own political agenda on this which
many of you are and always do you could
kind of separate and go how shocked were
you that there were press they killed
his mother it was shocking to you how
shocking was it to you that this was a
firestorm that guy he was like the most
eligible bachelor in the world I don't
know why people want into the blood cult
and she then started I want to watch
this trailer and then we will comment
more on it but again if you're
disagreeing with me here that's okay I
haven't seen the full thing but I think
I'm right and I think you think I'm
right too
it's really hard it's really hard now
because what happened
Royal Rockstar
yeah stop it for a second oh it's just
in Africa feeding a pig a salad and then
I'll met Megan and Megan toad made it
everybody was calling her the n-word in
their Castle so then all came to
California that's really what I mean so
like the people at Netflix like Okay so
let's let's unpack that can we unpack
that well that's pretty much the story
then Megan always in Africa and we'll
always do in there easy God is bird and
it stands up have you ever seen that
it's a bird but it walks no we it's you
mean like a penguin no it's not because
they're in the code like penguins are in
the cold places where people go skiing
but in Africa it's like a big bird and
we was watching it walk and then I met
Megan and she came and she put my baby
in her and then she said everybody in
the castle they were saying all kinds of
bad things about about her calling her
all kinds of names and such so I had to
move here and now we live here in
Netflix
everything changed
there's a hierarchy of the family you
know there's leaking but there's also
planting of stories there was a war
against Megan to suit other people's
agendas
by the way cut that if there was a war
she won if they were you can't go to war
with an actress you dumb vampire freak
she won as of course she would a
Hollywood actress is the only thing that
is more cold and has more blood loss
than these monsters so if there was a
war against her good on her this is a
pro-megan show if I saw her in Montecito
at the play at the San Ysidro Ranch
having dinner I would just do black
power to her
I would because what do I give a [ __ ]
about these freaks good for her I have
no problem that she ripped apart this
thing
it's a dirty game
pain and suffering of women marrying
into this institution this feeling
Frenzy
I was terrified honey what did you think
it was what did you think it was
all right no one knows your Fortress but
what did you think it was when you go to
you were gonna marry into the Royal
Family
did you not imagine they may have been
raped they invented racism they quite
literally are co-colonists like with all
these idiots on Twitter and they're like
decolonize and blah blah blah they're
talking about that they started it
imperialism Conquest subjugating people
on the basis of race what are you
talking about yes America's done that
too but I mean what are you saying
you're shocked at how racist they were
so something feels off and again it's
not a negative towards her per se it
feels like she ran a little bit of a
scam little bit of a game
she got in there supposedly they said
some things to her that were not nice
and I I imagine that probably is the
case
um I think someone said how dark will
the baby be or something that's not nice
but she's also not even that dark so why
would they say that or I don't believe
that it's weird I don't believe I don't
believe it but maybe it happened I can't
I don't I don't know I want uh that uh
because here's the other thing about
Harry he's not he's not Prince Charles's
kid Diana [ __ ]
her [ __ ] I forget who but like her
dance instructor this is kind of well
known and because Prince uh Charles and
Prince
um uh William look a lot alike but if
you Google Harry's real father it's like
Chloe and OJ it's like boom immediately
you know so he's kind of half half and
half out anyway
and the problem is you know his real
father uh Prince Harry's real father is
definitely I don't think it's Prince
Charles I think it's a guy that Diana go
to Princess Diana affair
Harry's dad because I think it's
definitely
a almost I don't want to say it's
obvious
but I do want to say that a lot of it's
a commonly held
belief that at the end of the day he may
not be
the child of Charles because Charles
does not yeah James Hewitt right there
former Lover James Hewitt go down
he's not he doesn't look anything like
Charles
he does not look anything like Charles
but he does look a lot like this guy
James Hewitt
and I think that at the end of the day
maybe that plays into this too like
maybe he's like you know listen they
weren't honest with me about
everything there are secrets
um there are secrets in my family
and you know I'm not being dealt with
honestly so if I'm not being dealt with
honestly you know maybe I'm gonna get
the [ __ ] out of here I don't know but
yeah that look look at this guy he looks
so much more like Harry than Charles
I mean that's uncanny
I mean this is crazy he's a ginger he
looks exactly like him
so I don't again I'm not trying to
spread uh rumors or false information
but I think that like you know
The Royals are interesting people but
this idea that Meghan Markle had no clue
uh I had no idea like oh my God the
pressure now the Press are gonna get
involved now I can't believe it the the
I was so shocked when it was revealed
that I was dating one of the most famous
people in the world who happened to be a
prince that the Press had an interest in
that
and I was shocked when I announced my
engagement to him
that the Press had an interest in that
I'm not saying it's not brutal I'm not
saying it's not vicious but I'm saying
that I think there's a little more uh to
what's going on than meets the eye I
think she went over there and she's like
we can do an exit
and we can get out of this thing and go
to the U.S and be really really famous
for a whole nother said and I think the
other uh inbred uh I think the other
people are jealous I think William and
Kate might be a little jealous they're
like [ __ ] you know I like the UK but
it's rainy and damp and they're over
here in Montecito and usually it's warm
and nice and you know they're they're by
the pool it's a different life and I
don't know maybe you know obviously the
royal family there's benefits to being a
part of it but I mean they did they made
an egg out I'm still gonna finish the
documentary because I don't have I don't
have my full thoughts on it yet but my
initial impressions are that Megan ran a
little bit of a game knowing full well
that this guy probably wasn't nearly as
attached to his family as he claimed for
many reasons and Megan was like okay
yeah they're being dicks to us they're
kind of piece of [ __ ] let's get out of
here but we can't leave unless it's a
scandal because that's where the money
is you see they didn't have any money
Diana's inheritance wasn't that much
money she only made three or five
million from Suits her net wasn't High
his net wasn't High
okay they got a 10 million Mortgage in
Montecito that did not come from either
one of their pockets
enter Netflix
Netflix goes get over here
she has the Oprah interview she goes
this has got to be a massive Royal
Scandal where we are resigning because
the Royal
imperialist Blood Dynasty family also
stunningly shockingly happens to be
racially insensitive
they're also racially insensitive
I can't believe it the people that
invented imperialism somewhat I know
that they didn't technically but they
are racially they have some blind spots
they have blind spots racially so that
was their Scandal and the Scandal was
such that they started a production
company Archer well Productions where
they're now making things about uh the
anti-racist stuff
and they're like we're gonna make things
like there was one cartoon they're gonna
make about a girl who goes through
history and it's like I'm a I'm a smart
girl and she'd go back to like the black
plague or whatever and
she'd be like I'm a smart girl and we're
rats they're doing this I know it
because I'm smart like with some cartoon
like that which is a girl and but they
canceled it or whatever but like that
that's what I'm you know what I mean
like people don't want that they want to
watch Wednesday they want to watch Harry
Potter but slightly different they don't
want your [ __ ]
start making that if Harry and Megan
start making that now that you're in
America you got to start making racist
programming if you want to make real
money but they have a hundred million
dollars and um
I wish them the best all right everybody
you know that the holidays are around uh
the corner and everybody right now is
just doing everything they can to
um you know make a little extra money in
their shipping things but they don't
want to you know their companies that
you can't really you know I mean what's
going on here you know if you're
shipping something and you're thinking
about shipping you're not thinking about
you know doing the making the Snowman
into a little you know Capital Rider or
whatever you're selling
so what you have to do is use ship
station okay it's the most wonderful
time of the year but it's also the most
hectic
okay what ship station is is it's an
amazing service that allows you to
basically put all of the [ __ ] back
office needs on ship station okay they
work with all your favorite places to
sell online including Amazon Etsy eBay
Shopify and more manage every order from
one simple dashboard automate routine
shipping tasks print shipping labels and
they easily compare rates and deliver
delivery times to optimize every
shipment and with Enterprise solutions
that make Warehouse optimization easy
ship station scales when you do nobody
wants to think too hard during the
holidays luckily ship station is a
no-brainer you'll save time money and
stress during the holiday Rush when you
sign up using my promo code you'll
um get two months to try it free are you
guys crazy two months to try it free
that's over 130 000 companies have grown
their e-commerce business with ship
station and 98 of companies that St that
use ship station that stick with it for
about a year they become customers for
life
I'm telling you I love ship station
right I mean just so many people use it
Wolfgang Puck home on it
a lot of stuff
sock Club
use promo code Tim Dillon today at
shipstation.com to sign up for a free
60-day trial that's two months free
especially if you're starting a new
business you want to see how you're
going to work out online right now
60-day trial it allows you two months
you can use this service for free just
focus on marketing and shipping [ __ ]
shipstation.com promo code Tim Dillon
Tim
t-i-l-l-o-n movies are tanking right now
by the way there's a lot of these
Prestige movies they're spending a lot
of money on high-end movies and they're
tanking they're not doing well yeah so
Hollywood right now they're losing a lot
of money on these I guess High concept
films and you know some people are
saying that they're just
they're depressing like Hollywood
Washington despair is oscar-oriented
films like licorice pizza nightmare
alley flatlined to the box office
um they're Prestige films right the
things that you know we kind of grew up
with these dramas that are great and
people love them and they win Awards and
the Blockbusters that make so much money
allow for these films to be made right
um
um but some of them are really really
bombing like Armageddon time costs
roughly 30 million dollars to make and
collected 1.9 million at the North
American box office
tar which is the Blanchette one costs 35
million including marketing ticket sales
totaling 5.3 million
Universal spent around 55 million in
making Market she said which also took
in 5.3 million devotion caused well over
100 million and has generated 14 million
in ticket sales so a lot of these movies
are tanking and
um people are not going to see them at
the box office people are either at home
they're watching them on streaming they
don't care and these you know these uh
Studios they put a lot of money into
these films so that they are big box
office hits right this is the metric by
which Studios really can tell what is
and isn't working and the metric is
tickets at the box office that's how
it's done it's how it's always been done
and
that isn't working right now they are
not doing enough because some of these
movies are just sad like it's like
you know it's like you know the Fable
men's about Stephen Spielberg and I'm
sure it's great it's like Steven
Spielberg's life story and Paul Franklin
Dano I'm sure it's fine but whatever but
some of them are sad like there's
something about Emmett Till his mother
that's coming up I think it's later in
this article
um where you have like you know it's
just it's you know there's been a lot of
things yeah uh the core of cinephiles is
still
tuning out till focused on Mamie till
Mobley whose son Emmett Till was
murdered in Mississippi in 1955 was
collected 8.9 million in the U.S and
Canada that's not nothing
for an emotionally challenging film
I mean it's it's these these deal with
real hard topics right this is not a
feel-good
film Emmett Till's story it's an
important story and what it needs to be
told but this is not like let's get the
family in the station wagon
and let's go see Emmett Till get lynched
this is not a fun summer film right that
look can we be honest about that
well
we're solving it
we're solving it
I love athletic greens everyone I know
loves athletic greens I'm telling you
right now this is a great way everybody
has problems with their God through
eating too much sugar too much white
bread too much garbage people go out
they drink everything what you need to
do
um is start taking athletic Koreans okay
if you want better gut health if you
want more energy if you want an
optimized immune system uh this is what
you need to do I'm telling you what is
athletic greens uh you're absorbing 75
high quality vitamins minerals Whole
Food store superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right the special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health your nervous
system your immune system your energy
recovery focus and aging all these
things you can do I'm telling you it's
so easy this is not yogurt it's not
garbage there's no cooking or anything
it's so easy uh I'm I'm telling you this
is just something that you will never
regret uh putting in your body I know
people that take this now they're in the
Olympics literally they've won gold
medals in the Olympics from this
literally started out like fat slobs you
know they're literally Olympian gold
medalists because of athletic greens
primarily
um
athletic green says over 7 000 five-star
reviews to make it easy athletic Koreans
is going to give you a free one-year
supply of immune supporting vitamin D
and you need that right now everything's
going crazy again vitamin D and five
free travel packs with your first
purchase all you have to do is visit
athleticqueens.com Tim Dylan again
that's athleticqueens.com Tim Dillon to
take ownership over your health and pick
up the ultimate daily nutritional
Insurance it is so easy to use this
stuff I'm telling you Rogan loves it all
of everyone I know that really takes
your health seriously really likes
athletic greens okay they also donated
1.2 million meals to kids in 2020 that's
really awesome
um and for every purchase they donate to
organizations helping to get nutritious
food to Kids in Need I mean that's
really really cool
Hollywood has figured it out there's one
director that they have not tapped yet
to make a film one voice that has not
been heard from one artist who begs for
a long form representation of her
thoughts Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift is making a feature
directing debut for Searchlight Pictures
and do you know what this they're
letting her do and I was shocked about
this she is playing the daughter of a
plantation owner who teaches a Slave how
to read and play guitar
that's a fact
she is playing the daughter of a
plantation owner who teaches his slave
reading and writing and then teaches him
how to play guitar I don't like that
personally I'd I say no I'm kidding of
course that is untrue she's actually
playing a Nazi's wife
who gets Jews out of Poland
but it's like this uh the the the the
the the [ __ ] the thing with Juliet
and Julie Andrews the uh The Sound of
Music it's like the sound of music with
Taylor Swift I'm kidding that is also a
lie she's playing swimmer Leah Thomas
Transformer Leah Thomas Taylor Swift is
playing her and it's a movie and it's
kind of a comedy it's called don't look
at my Finn
and it trans uh swimmer Leah Thomas and
Taylor Swift and it's a goofy fun trans
romp through the locker room that's what
it is uh of course all of those things
are not true uh we don't we don't know
what the Taylor Swift film will be but
we do know that it will be
I mean maybe it's maybe it's Casey
Anthony
maybe she plays Casey Anthony
and they make a movie for the red state
so they find out it was just a cabal of
satanic cannibals that have killed her
child
and then Casey Anthony [ __ ] runs for
Congress and wins maybe she plays a
Ukrainian [ __ ] who speaks into Russian
poisons Putin that would be for the blue
States
I don't know because Taylor's in the
middle there but she's making her future
directorial debut with Searchlight
picture the singer-songwriter and
director has written in original scripts
which will be
produced by the oscar-winning studio
behind Nomad land and the shape of water
other key details like a plot and
casting are being kept Under Wraps until
a later date it's going to be
interesting it's gonna be like a sweet
Summer movie right where she's like mad
at a dude and it's like it's the hot
summer Nashville and everybody's singing
it's gonna be a big soundtrack
and uh so and that's and that that's the
future
that's the future if you have an
audience like Taylor Swift whether you
know anything about Cinema whether you
know anything about movies you're going
to be tapped to direct a movie and then
you're it will it'll be a two-hour
Taylor Swift song that's what it'll be
two hours of Taylor Swift and her issues
with a guy who she met at the ice cream
truck or whatever it was and that'll be
what it is two hours of that and then
they'll just start handing it out yeah
Doja cat will have a film that no one
will be able to understand
um but why not I mean this is this is
because because people are just giving
up and this is giving up so when you've
given up you just go Taylor Swift has
sold more tickets than the pope let her
it'll be fine whatever the hell she
wants and I'm sure and it'll probably be
fine it'll probably be decent and I
don't think that
um it'll be much worse than some of the
other things
um but I I mean I can't imagine
Searchlight recently released uh the
menu with dark the comic horror film and
Martin McDon is the Banshees vinasheeren
which is a major Oscar Contender it's
amazing
and now they're also going to release uh
Taylor Swift's two-hour
Ode to you know I don't know being stood
up at the dance or whatever the hell and
I don't I have no beef with her God
bless her she certainly came out of the
winner in the Kanye thing but I don't
know if I need uh two hours of that of
her but you know I mean she's rich and
she's got a fan base and you get to do
what you want you get to do what you
want none of these other things that
work because they keep making movies
where it's like Kate Blanchett is like
the conductor of an orchestra and if she
has Ms or whatever and people are sad
they're just like enough of it we need
something fun can't keep watching and
until we can't keep watching very
serious middle-aged menopausal white
women who are like trying to accomplish
things we have to find something a bit
goofy a bit fun a bit and maybe Taylor
Swift will do I don't know but she's
gonna it's gonna be like a fun because
she's like liked by both sides and just
culture War so it'll be interesting to
see what Taylor Swift decides to do like
it's probably going to be just a rot
like a little bit of a rom-com like a
country
rom-com and uh
yeah I mean I I can't imagine it'll be
good
but I don't know an 11th person was
killed by being thrown in uh in the New
York City Subway or maybe they're not
being thrown but they're being killed on
the sub of the NYPD is investigating a
killing inside a Greenwich Village
subway station they responded to a call
of an unconscious man just after
midnight Thursday in the West 4th Street
and 6th Avenue Station officers found a
man unconscious and unresponsive near
the stairwell and he's number 11 this
year this is the 11th Subway kill the
subway in New York City is becoming like
untenable like insane like for people to
actually use it it's it's becoming like
a roll of the dice people are getting
assaulted uh people are getting murdered
and um and that is not worth the price
that is continually escalating it
continually raise the price of the
subway so just drop the price if people
if you're gonna let people get killed
drop the price make it cheaper make it
more cost effective to get last
three dollars to get a slash on your
face seems high make it less money so
that people can get violently assaulted
and still have enough money for gauze
and [ __ ] peroxide and all the things
they need to clean their wounds out when
they get home it's a nice happy medium
but our cocaine addict mayor Eric Adams
in New York City uh other than doing
blow and hanging out at clubs has
decided he's going to start putting more
of these crazy mental patients in jail
and hopefully there will be less of them
on the New York City subway to murder
you
that is the hope he's going to start
moving homeless and by the way Karen
bass was just elected in L.A just moved
all the homeless people out of City Hall
for her mayoral inauguration
now I am offering if you have the money
if you have the uh wherewithal to do
this with me I will fund it I want to
move the homeless back
the night before the bass inauguration
LA Times with LA swearing in a new mayor
Crews work to move homeless encampments
near City Hall well that feels like a
lie and we hate lies
so if you want to move the homeless back
in front of city hall with me
let's get to Vans let's get the trucks
let's put them back where they belong in
front of the camera it's LA everyone
wants to be in front of the camera in
fact it would only be fair if as the
mayor is getting inaugurated in La
homeless people are wandering around in
the background like a horror movie it
should look like someone is being
inaugurated in a in a literal horror
movie where it's a zombie apocalypse and
someone's just standing there at a
Podium with their hand up taking the
oath of office that's what it should
look like it should not they should not
sanitize it for the public it should not
be cleaned up it should make you pause
it should be a meme
it should make you pause you should see
the inauguration and you should look at
it and you should go what because in the
background you should just see blurry
figures wandering around just these
blurry figures wandering around trying
to get drugs or food or water or
whatever however and they should just be
kind of swaying and you know that kind
of fentanyl look to them and they and
and then there should be just guards on
either side of Karen bass we don't want
anyone to get hurt but and the guard
should be there and they should be like
shoeing the people away we're doing an
inauguration for the mayor of this great
City
but unfortunately
um an official with the LA homeless
Services Authority which participated in
Thursday's operation also referred
questions about the first and spring
encampment to garcetti's office
saying what's going on here
to be unequivocally clear the council
member did not request this operation
see
here's the reality everybody's
really uncomfortable with seeing the
truth of what this place has become
especially the mayor
and the mayor is going to do everything
in her power to like La has always done
Market a different version of reality
and she's marketing a different version
of Reality by having those homeless
encampments moved
right before she takes the uh oath of
office in downtown
and what a lie what a [ __ ]
unfortunate because
I think
there's a way to just give all those
homeless people drugs and make them
happy what if you gave those homeless
people all the drugs they wanted and
gave them you know some of them speak
English a lot of them give them give
them sheets with music on it for a song
that they can sing behind the Karen bass
why are we throwing them away you have
them there they're a captive audience
they're willing to learn they're willing
to learn for food or crack or fentanyl
whatever they want if they can get and
how nice would it be to see the LA mayor
the first black female mayor getting
inaugurated and maybe the people in the
back are doing the song from The
Temptations or something something nice
now yes you can get them in costume put
them in hair and makeup
they I don't see a problem with that it
should be a production it's it's
Hollywood shouldn't it be a production
and yes not all of them are gonna follow
along some of them are gonna get
frustrated they're not doing as well
they some of them may bite others some
of them are not going to show up for
rehearsal right not everyone's a hard
worker but you will get some of them
when you promise them drugs you say I
will give you drugs if you learn this so
what's a good La sir I'm thinking right
now what is a that's a real because New
York has New York New York but like La
doesn't really have any la
we love La get up we love LA on YouTube
I want to hear this song Because if the
homeless could stand behind Karen bass
and sing We Love la
wild just [ __ ] up and bleeding
it would be beautiful it would be much
better than making the move
oh I love La the oh the we love LA or I
love la
and same thing it's the Randy Newman
song
this they I cannot believe this was not
pitched too hard this seems like such a
great
now you can imagine the homeless people
they're all standing behind
Karen bass as she's being inaugurated
to be the mayor of hell
and everybody's there
and all the city officials are there New
York City
foreign
if you've lost your sheet we can get you
another one it's not just kind of sing
along just sway if you don't have your
[ __ ] and you just see the people out of
it like crazy boys
it's not bad at all
this would have been so much of a better
solution
okay and she's just checking on them
every now and then and they're just like
and she's like well isn't that nice
she's motioning to the cameras you know
someone hits someone in head with a
bottle they removed immediately but most
people are doing well
what's the chorus
I love that like perfect
love it we love it everyone say we love
it
tell them to homeless people we love it
we love it great everyone's gone Karen
this is beautiful we love it yeah all
right yeah that's I mean that's clearly
a much better solution than moving these
people out of their [ __ ] homes you
sick [ __ ]
it's crazy
that makes no sense
that makes no sense when they're there
and they could literally do a song and a
nice number with some simple minimal
choreography it doesn't have to be a
insanely it's not Beyonce we don't need
a crazy dance but some minimal
choreography
you know some just just I love La we
love La they're all in I love La shirts
you give them all hats
they're getting merged they should each
get what they call a swag bag afterwards
where they have the merch uh Karen bass
is inauguration they could all get
shirts with Karen bass on it with her
face on it uh I love our new mayor I
love LA on the back
and then they could just go running uh
through the streets
raycon earbuds are so great because
let's be honest I mean we all need to
listen to music and podcasts we cannot
be in our own heads with our own
thoughts raycons wireless earbuds
headphones and speakers offer premium
sound useful features and an almost
custom comfortable fit up to 54 hours of
battery life anyone you give them to a
fun to use for them right away whether
they use the speakers to start a party
in the living room or escape the party
completely and use the earbuds for some
much needed Zen meditation and the
person gifting them you've you've got a
lot as and as the person gifting them
you've got a love that they start at
half the price of other premium audio
brands
and for the next month raycon will have
a countdown to Christmas with a new
pop-up flash deal for you to take
advantage of every single day I mean
this is amazing this is great this is
such a great stocking stuffer for the
people here's the earbuds go away leave
me alone the raycon website also offers
free shipping free returns and buy now
pay later options plus a 30-day
happiness guarantee buy now pay later
options nothing better than that plus a
30-day happiness guarantee call to
actions right now go to buy raycon.com
Jim to get 15 off sitewide with code
holiday
so you go to that's code holiday at
byraycon.com Tim for 15 off your raycon
purchases by raycon.com Tim it's a great
way to support the show great way to win
friends blah blah blah Amazing by the
way everyone's got covered now again
it's so annoying I was gonna do a little
bit of a Christmas party but I'm not
doing it
everyone is Coveted in Los Angeles it's
so [ __ ] annoying New York City
they're putting the masks back on
everybody's got everything here it's
sneezing sniffling coughing people have
gotten a lot of upper respiratory things
people have the flu I spoke to Christy
Stefano he just got over the flu
hospitals are like more filled now than
they ever have been
um
because I guess after Thanksgiving all
these families met and then everybody uh
control I'm being tested all the time
I'm on a project where I have to get
tested but uh the flu is really hitting
people and the upper respiratory stuff
is really hitting people
and it's unfortunate and um
you know I mean this is unfortunate so
if you can stay healthy keep your wits
about you here and just uh basically
watch this Harry and Megan thing watch
it because it is entertaining it's fun
uh you have to remember they don't want
to be in the spotlight
is the thing you have to remember about
them
they don't want to be in the spotlight
which is why they've formed a production
company
you see
that uh Meghan Markle evades the
spotlight that's why she was on a TV
show
okay hmm that's why she then dated uh a
prince and married him
that's why she now has a production
company
that's why she has a 100 million dollar
deal with Netflix that's why she went on
Oprah because she hates the spotlight
okay
all those things can exist in your head
at the same time
you have to you have to just understand
that she hates the spotlight and the
only way that she feels like she can get
out of the spotlight is by get going
more and more and more into the
spotlight
now I'm not saying that the the Press of
the people over there aren't racist and
they didn't they didn't put it through
hell I'm not saying that uh she wasn't
maybe shocked at the scope of whatever
but I to me it's she's not a naive girl
she's not a dummy she knows what goes on
I'm sure even knowing that it came as a
surprise to her
now it says the royal family is
breathing a sign of relief over uh Harry
and Megan's Netflix series so it turns
out the royal family isn't sweating
Megan and Harry as a hotly anticipated
docu series didn't have quite as many
Bombshells as they expected Royal expert
Jonathan Sarah sakurdati
uh spoke to U.S weekly about the Royal
reaction to the sussex's Netflix show
saying I don't think there was very much
there that wasn't that was particularly
new or would have worried them that much
he added the family's breathing aside
relief on that listen it's bored it's
kind of boring it's it's someone
entertaining it's a nice easy light
watch you're not getting the bombshell
she didn't it's not like she walked in
on the bloodletting ceremony where they
were eating people she simply you know
you you she couldn't deal with the
spotlight this is the problem it's
intense scrutiny
that came along with dating this guy
apparently was too much for her to bear
and the only way out of that is to move
to Hollywood and getting a deal with
Netflix it makes sense
she wants her privacy back
dummies
she wants her privacy back
that's why she has a 100 million dollar
deal with Netflix to do documentaries
about her
because she likes her private life
it doesn't admit it but kudos to her I
like to see people win
it makes me happy I like her I like
what's behind her eyes it's it's it's a
it's a it's a thing
that will jump out of her when she dies
and jump into another person
and then animate them too
do wild [ __ ]
growing up where she grew up the fact
that she's married a prince living in
Montecito you can't not respect that you
have to respect it did she destroy a
lizard family to get this sure who cares
who gives a [ __ ] shut up
I respect what she did
I respect what lives behind her eyes I
respect that vacant Darkness that's
behind the eyes of every actress this is
what I respect and this is and I've
talked to so many of them and there's
just something there that isn't there
and there's something that
doesn't have a form it's an ambition
it's a control it's a need to transcend
where you are and go somewhere else it's
a need to arrange the world in a way uh
that pleases you a way that you feel
that you can succeed it's a competitive
Advantage it's a Darkness it's an
emptiness it's a vacancy it's a glare
and I like it it makes me feel
comfortable I see it in many people that
I look at I see behind their eyes you
don't look at the eye you look behind
the eyes what is behind them is that raw
ambition it is that empty Hollow vacant
Elevator Shaft that goes straight to the
bottom straight to the ID it goes it is
the spiders that crawl in the back of
your head just waiting for the flies to
feast
using your tongue and your mouth to
weave the webs that you catch other
people in it is actually something that
is quite nice it is quite nice There's
Something Beautiful about that darkness
that that that place that she goes where
she lived above a garage in the valley
and it was hot and it was stinky and
smelly and the garbage was everywhere
and now she's in Montecito with the
breeze and it hits her by the pool and
she's looking at her child going that
baby's not growing up how I grew up she
used what she had she clawed she she
clawed she just did it and you have to
respect it that thing that gets lost in
her smile that's there and it's it's
what drives civilization forward because
men want to [ __ ] these women and that's
what makes civilization happen folks
okay not everybody wants to [ __ ] the 3am
pincushion pig pig sometimes you want a
real hottie and sometimes that hottie
has plans for you and she had plans for
this [ __ ] and and she executed them
brilliantly
and that's the thing I think we all have
to really remember we all have to really
remember that it's a story of winning
it's a sort of a woman winning and it's
not something that
um you know people are understanding it
in the wrong way they're like well she
took him from his family you know
perhaps sure number one we don't even
know we just covered earlier maybe it is
in his family and number two his new
family is with her and Netflix he's part
of the Netflix family and that's a
family it's a family with a lot of
[ __ ] money
so you know listen
uh God bless
her you can see it's behind the eyes
it's the winning it says she's very calm
the way she talks is very calm very calm
and the things that happen and we were
just we were very shocked at the racism
and we just what we had to do was win
and choose winning and there's nothing
there's nothing to be gleaned from this
there's nothing to be understood or
taken from this that isn't really uh
positive this is a positive all-around
for everybody
um it's good to see an old blood cult
get you know temporarily tested and
thrown out of whack
um it's also good to uh to see you know
uh a woman like that win because in her
mind every interaction she's had in her
life is about that moment every
interaction that she's ever had is about
the moment where she could is [ __ ] from
the valley who's a [ __ ] on a show
Suits it was ending she was not an
a-lister by any means by any any means
just wanted to win
she didn't know why she wasn't
particularly obsessed with any aspect of
winning it didn't even matter it wasn't
about a car it wasn't necessarily about
a house although those things are nice
it was about a position it was about an
heir that she wanted to exist in and
this is you know this idea of being the
modern place you saw Princess Diana she
goes I'm gonna kind of do what Princess
Diana did before they kill me
kind of interesting kind of interesting
before they got to her but do the Royals
Strike Back
do the Royals
Strike Back
what an interesting thought I hope not I
hope not I hope not
not but the queen has just died the old
lizard has died
I wonder if there's a thought in the
palace do we just do we clip them
do we clip them
hmm
interesting
answers well I'm happy I'm not the
princess of England
I'll tell you that
I am happy that I'm not the princess of
England we appreciate you uh we covered
uh a lot of these Bitcoin guys getting
killed on the patreon that's really
interesting and a little scary down
there in Puerto Rico if you're down in
Puerto Rico and you got a lot of Bitcoin
don't go to the beach
um it's uh a real problem but uh that's
up on the patreon right now uh any
tickets live dates Tim dilloncomedy.com
uh we've got shows coming up New Year's
Eve I'm going to be in Irvine California
for the whole weekend I'm also going to
be at the spotlight casino in Indio out
there in the desert if you live anywhere
out there uh you could come see me that
should be a lot of fun uh we also have
the Oxnard improv up as well those are
on
teamdillaccomedy.com uh tickets you can
get them there
um and we will uh see everybody soon
don't
uh watch this documentary and don't have
a uh take on it per se uh from this show
go and give it give everyone the uh
their own hearing give everyone their
own hearing and see what happens but
I hope I hope she's out but if the
Royals get her if they get her if the if
they get her
if she gets eaten by a dolphin or
something out there
[ __ ] well you you might just have to go
you gotta hand it to the old lizards
I'll be watching closely good night